[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous bonsoir
Grégory bons
on se retrouve pour une émission sur
notre 31 pour une émission spéciale Noël
absolument quel est le programme Grégory
bah écoutez ce soir dans cette émission
on va vous donner des idées locales on
va pouvoir peut-être voir le sommaire à
s'afficher pour célébrer les fêtes des
cadeaux yvelinois a placé sous le sapin
et des produits du terroir à mettre sur
votre table de réveillon il est possible
également de fêter la fin d'année de
façon éco-responsable tous nos bons
conseils pour un Noël zéro déchet
plutôt que d'offrir un animal à vos
proches pourquoi ne pas offrir plutôt un
beau Noël directement aux animaux
accueillir un animal à ses côtés n'est
pas un acte anodin face aux abandons qui
restent élevés la SPA Société
protectrice des animaux et milite pour
l'adoption responsable une décision à
prendre avec réflexion et sérieux et le
dit Juillac chef d'équipe à la SPA de
plaisir et notre invité
et puis à l'occasion des vacances de
Noël TV 78 vous livre sa sélection des
idées de sortie à faire dans les
Yvelines enfiler votre manteau n'oubliez
pas votre écharpe Vauban et votre bonnet
c'est parti pour le 7 8 spécial fin
d'année vous lisiez Mathilde nous on est
plutôt sur notre 31 ce soir ce qu'on a
installé tranquillement en plateau avec
vous avec aussi les journalistes de la
rédaction TV 78 il y a notamment Gabriel
bontier bonsoir prêt
pour cette nouvelle heure d'information
avec des idées spéciales Noël et
d'ailleurs Gabriel vous nous avez
concocté vos habitués à l'idée de sortie
il est spéciale vacances il faut le dire
sur le week-end qui arrive mais sur les
deux semaines de vacances qui arrivent
et ce sera des idées de sortie spéciale
Noël bien sûr
vous allez nous présenter des des idées
de cadeaux et de décoration écolo
de fait à partir d'agrumes des idées de
cadeaux aussi zéro déchet
chet et on verra enfin un emballage
aussi zéro déchet en tissu voilà ce sera
notre fil rouge tout au long de cette
émission nous accompagner également
Régine rallès bonsoir Régine bonsoir et
donc avec vous c'est plutôt alors des
idées cadeaux des artisans aussi
yvelinois on va voir un petit peu l'eau
à la bouche avec vous exactement et on
va aussi parler de bières de biscuits et
de vin et il n'est pas là en plateau ce
soir mais on retrouve aussi Michael el
midoro qui est au centre Westfield de
Vélizy 2 Michael ennemie Doro je sais
pas si vous nous entendez je vous
entends Mathilde je vois que tout le
monde est très bien habillé autour
on a fait on a fait des efforts Michael
on imagine que là le centre Westfield
Parly 2 est en effervescence à
l'approche Vélizy 2 à l'approche des
fêtes de fin d'année
effectivement on a installé depuis
environ une vingtaine de minutes ici
dans le centre ouest-five Vélizy 2 et ça
commence à monter petit à petit
les gens viennent
seulement il reste que quelques jours
avant Noël donc il y a beaucoup de monde
ici à Vélizy
et un Platon on retrouve aussi Nicolas
dandry qui arrive qui arrive également
sur son 31 Grégory mais on a la même
couleur de nœud papillon de papillon on
est un peu sur les mêmes tons bleu voilà
c'est également avec le petit nœud
papillon rouge Nicolas c'est l'habituel
couille je sais que c'est un rendez-vous
vous avez l'habitude on a l'habitude de
retrouver le jeudi oui et puis en plus
on a affaire à deux présentateurs qui
sont plutôt des Winners dans ce dans ce
quiz là donc oui voilà un quiz spécial
Noël forcément alors avec on va les
découvrir à la fois des producteurs pour
des idées de cadeaux le papa Noël on
sait qu'il a ces petits lutins dans les
Yvelines et il y a il peut se fournir
chez certains producteurs yvelinois et
puis on va aussi aller sur deux
questions concernant et bien des
cuisiniers des chefs enfin voilà j'en
dis pas plus parce que je sais que vous
trichez vous essayez toujours de
chercher mes questions mais là ils sont
bien cachés en régime
on n'a jamais cette intention là et tout
au long de cette émission de cette
édition spéciale nous serons aussi
accompagnés de Elodie Juillac bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes chef d'équipe à
la SPA de plaisir et vous êtes aussi
accompagné de Tyson
juste en dessous on le voit alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter et bien
Tyson c'est un petit chien croisé donc
Ratier et staff de 3 ans et qui est chez
nous déjà depuis presque un an et qui a
déjà été adopté deux fois donc il est
revenu voilà
très câlin très câlin très protecteur
mais il n'aime pas les enfants voilà
de faire un peu plus sa connaissance
tout à l'heure on viendra aussi sur la
situation actuelle à un refuge SPA de
plaisir on fera le point sur les
adoptions et aussi on parlera de comment
on peut aussi et bien ravir nos animaux
directement avec des idées de cadeaux
spécial animaux pour nos animaux nos
compagnons à glisser sous le sapin on
aura également d'autres choses au
programme dans cette émission on viendra
sur la dernière la tradition du Noël
décalé ça se passait il y a quelques
jours à la Commanderie de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines royalement alors Tyson est
en train de monter sur la table du
statut voilà on est on est en direct
mais Tyson peut monter sur la table s'il
le souhaite il y a pas de souci on aura
d'autres invités on vous le disait des
idées cadeaux sera avec notre
chroniqueuse ATIS barrée mais également
à un invité du château de Versailles
Château de Versailles spectacle pour
nous parler du parcours du roi qui
revient tout à fait qui revient qui
revient aussi cette année et dressé et
c'est l'heure de débuter ce 7 8 spécial
fin d'année
[Musique]
et on commence cette émission par la
rencontre de Léa beau d'originaire de
Bois-d'Arcy elle a créé sa marque de
maroquinerie haut de gamme LB
maroquinerie Gabriel Gontier est allé à
sa rencontre je vous propose de regarder
son reportage
sac à main portefeuille ou encore porte
carte en avril 2020 les à LB
maroquinerie l'artisienne de 24 ans crée
de la maroquinerie haut de gamme et
colorée aussi bien pour les femmes que
pour les hommes donc du coup là je suis
sur une commande pour Noël d'un petit
sac Camille en fait c'est une
sacoche qui qui se met aussi bien à la
ceinture que en banane donc là c'est
pour un modèle Homme et là je suis en
train de faire en fait les finitions
donc j'arrive sur la fin du sac donc
c'est les finitions de tranche de la
bandoulière en fait de la sangle où je
viens appliquer en fait une teinture
pour avoir des bords qui soient plus
esthétiques entre chaque couche de
teinture je viens poncer pour lisser
remettre une couche et en général je
fais deux à trois couches
et entre chaque couche je laisse sécher
attirer depuis son enfance par les
activités manuelles et créatives c'est
après le bac qu'elle décide de se former
se spécialisant auprès des maisons de
luxe dans le savoir-faire français
patience et qualité sont les maîtres
mots pour travailler le cuir la
créatrice s'approvisionne donc auprès de
tannerie françaises et italienne en
règle générale je montre 15 et 20 heures
pour faire un sac pour chaque création
tout commence avec une idée ou une
commande et quelques coups de crayon sur
un carnet ça en fait c'est les dessins
de base en fait quand je réfléchis et
donc après je fais tout le côté après
technique donc je réfléchis à toutes les
parties qui va me falloir travailler les
dimensions
du coup donc le produit fini donc avec
la sangle qui est fixée donc qui est
ajustable
mettre en avant les métiers de
l'artisanat et le savoir-faire français
est important pour la jeune femme mois
durant mes études quand j'étais enfin
collège lycée on nous parlait pas du
tout de ces métiers là je les ai
découverts bien après et c'est vrai que
ça manque parce que
il y a des personnes qui sont faites
pour ça donc c'est dommage de passer à
côté en fait compter entre 20 et 400
euros pour vous offrir un de ces modèles
de quoi vous donner peut-être des idées
à mettre au pied du sapin
alors on a vu plusieurs modèles de sacs
dans ce sujet je sais pas si vous avez
des préférences autour de la table en
termes de forme de couleur peut-être moi
j'ai beaucoup aimé celui avec la petite
bandoulière Julien oui jolie aussi après
c'est pas trop ce que j'utilise
forcément mais bon en tout cas ça
donnera peut-être des idées de cadeaux
pour Noël c'est sûr c'est à moi j'aimais
bien le petit sac
ocre jaune ocre j'aimais beaucoup la
couleur
rouge je sais que ma chère étendre adore
le rouge donc ça peut être une idée de
cadeau effectivement à lui faire pour
pour les prochaines fêtes parce que le
cadeau est déjà fait pour le prochain
Noël voilà le 7 8 qui continue en Platon
on est installé on a notre invité on
disait Elodie juillet que de la SPA les
journalistes de la rédaction TV 78 on va
retrouver dans un instant également
Michael et demi d'euro depuis le centre
commercial Westfield Vélizy 2 il y a
aussi et bien les personnes qui
contribuent à cette émission en coulisse
les techniciens et également notre chef
d'édition Mélanie poquet vous voyez la
régie de TV 78 avec Ludovic avec Xavier
et avec Nathan qui sont installés et
Mélanie également derrière qui veille au
grain pour que toute cette émission se
déroule de la meilleure des manières et
de la régie et de ce plateau de tv78 je
lui dis on va aller vers le centre
commercial ouest-fille de velt Westfield
de Vélizy 2 vampire mon latin et Michel
et midoro et sur place alors il ne fait
pas du linge vitrine aujourd'hui Michael
il est allé prendre le pouls dans ce
rush de Noël puisqu'on l'imagine c'est
la pleine effervescence en ce moment du
côté du centre commercial et Michael
vous êtes avec le directeur de
l'établissement
exactement je suis avec Arnaud Beaucourt
qui est le directeur de Westfield Vélizy
2 alors Arnaud on le voit il y a
beaucoup de monde ce soir à Vélizy 2
alors bonsoir tout d'abord bonsoir
Michael bonsoir en effet il y a une
volumétrie client qui est extrêmement
intéressante et importante on revient
sur nos flux 2019 donc ce qui est plutôt
encourageant après deux périodes de
covid et d'année qui était extrêmement
compliqué pour tout le monde comme vous
pouvez le voir on a recréé la magie de
Noël et
pour les petits comme pour les grands
cette féerie de Noël et très très
intéressante et très importante et nos
flux sont réellement à hauteur de ce que
nous espions et c'est plutôt positif oui
il y a une certaine féerie il y a un
grand sapin qui a installé il y a le
Père Noël qui est juste derrière nous il
y a aussi des animations qui sont
proposées tout au long des vacances ici
à Westfield Vélizy 2 alors tout à fait
nous avons créé en effet tout un choix
et un panel d'activités en l'occurrence
essentiellement sur les mercredis samedi
et dimanche sur le thème du cirque cette
année le thème du cirque où vous avez
des acrobates des jongleurs des
animations pour les enfants pour pouvoir
justement savoir marcher sur des ballons
le théâtre de guignols qui a très très
bien fonctionné et plein d'autres
surprises que je vous invite à découvrir
sur notre site en l'occurrence vous
allez
de nos festivités les fêtes de Noël
c'est toujours un moment important pour
un directeur de centre commercial comme
vous alors c'est une période cruciale
c'est une période cruciale à la fois
pour les commerçants pour nous la
direction parce que c'est le moment de
l'année où en effet les flux d'activités
sont les plus importants et nous nous
devons de faire en sorte à ce que les
clients soient présents reviennent et
dans un dans une atmosphère en
l'occurrence qui soit la plus détendue
possible et la plus sympathique
en termes de chiffres est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner des chiffres sur la
fréquentation ici on multiplie le nombre
de visiteurs par combien alors sur la
période du mois de décembre les flux
sont quasiment doubles à ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on fait habituellement bien
évidemment ce qui est à noter c'est que
on était certes un petit peu en tendance
baissière sur les mois précédents aider
le Black Friday on a ressenti réellement
cette envie des clients de vouloir
revenir dans nos centres et reconsommer
à tel point que comme je l'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure on revient à nos
historiques en fait de volumétrie 2019
étant pour nous une année de référence
et une excellente année aujourd'hui on
est en phase avec la réception
encourageant ça veut dire qu'il y a pas
un frein au vu de la situation
économique à versa actuellement à
vouloir être réticent sur de l'achat en
fait de la consommation les gens cette
année on le sent ont envie de se libérer
ont envie de consommer ont envie
d'acheter ont envie de se retrouver on
est ici aussi un lieu de rencontre un
lieu du quotidien et ça se ressent au
quotidien dans dans le centre commercial
le panier moyen
le panier moyen m'a tout dépend en fait
de ce qu'on parle en termes de panier
moyen aujourd'hui on est à peu près dans
80 euros après la période de Noël et
forcément un peu plus importante que ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
habituellement ce qu'il faut noter c'est
que l'année dernière il y a encore ce
côté un petit peu anxiogène sur les
achats de Noël et surtout sur la pénurie
de jouets qu'on annonçait dès le mois de
novembre donc le mois de novembre on a
eu un format les gens se sont dit il
faut absolument que je mette des cadeaux
au pied du sapin pour les enfants alors
que cette année ça s'étale un peu plus
dans le temps quelque part et du coup
novembre était bien décembre s'annonce
extraordinaire et objectivement les
clients sont vraiment en rendez-vous et
plus particulièrement on le sent sur
certaines enseignes qui ont tendance à
monter en puissance et en charge donc
pas forcément des achats de dernière
minute alors non les je pense que alors
il y a forcément des achats dernière
minute type je le confirme effectivement
en fonction de
chacun clairement mais on voit que là
toutes les week-ends
et les clients en effet ont tendance un
peu plus anticiper au niveau de leurs
dépenses au niveau aussi de leur dans
leurs aspirations quelque part et force
cette constater comme vous avez pu le
voir au niveau du mail on a toutes
sortes de boutiques en l'occurrence qui
peut satisfaire tout type de clients en
fait toujours des sur le marché merci à
vous et vous l'aurez compris les achats
dernière minute sont encore possibles
ici à Westfield de Vélizy 2 mais ça a
commencé depuis le mois de novembre ici
le rush de Noël merci Michael merci
également à Arnaud ou beaucoup et on
vous retrouve dans dans quelques
instants on ne sait jamais si vous
croisez le Père Noël au centre
commercial Vélizy 2 on sait que nous il
a refusé notre invitation parce que on
imagine il prépare une tournée mondiale
chaque année on l'a vu passer il est
juste il est juste derrière moi mais il
y a beaucoup de photos avec les enfants
de venir malheureusement
aussi pour parler avec nous bon on aura
peut-être l'occasion de la voir au cours
de cette émission en tout cas sur ce
plateau non parce que il n'a pas le
temps on imagine qu'il a d'autres choses
à faire en vous retrouve tout à l'heure
Michael merci merci à vous et si vous
avez toujours pas trouvé vos idées de
cadeaux à offrir pour les fêtes de fin
d'année Julien Leroy je crois que vous
avez quelques idées à nous donner
quelques petites idées ouais justement
donc Anna et Anna et Marc est une
entrepreneur originaire de Maurepas elle
accompagne forme et conseils les
auto-entrepreneurs et les entreprises du
territoire 50 chinois pour les
éco-responsabiliser à travers des
ateliers et elle nous elle est venue
dans nos locaux il y a quelques jours
pour venir nous expliquer un petit peu
comment passer un nouvel zéro déchet
donc on va on va voir tout au long de
l'émission au cours d'un fil rouge
quelques tutos pour apprendre à décorer
des idées cadeaux des emballages
respectueux de l'environnement également
et on commence tout de suite avec une
proposition de décoration très originale
avec des agrumes donc on peut regarder
ça tout de suite
alors en autre style de guirlande pour
décorer la maison vous avez l'orange
alors vous connaissez sûrement le clou
de girofle piqué moi je trouve que les
clous de girofle c'est quand même des
boutons de fleurs c'est un peu dommage
mais bon s'ils sont un peu vieux ça peut
être pas mal moi je coupe l'orange en
petite tranche je vous ai préparé à
l'avance
voilà pas trop épaisse un demi
centimètre c'est parfait
je coupe mes tranches
je prends du fil et une aiguille bon
j'ai choisi un beau jaune la même
couleur que l'orange et puis je peux
faire ça avec plein d'agrumes du citron
jaune du citron vert même du
pamplemousse si je veux
j'enfile mon fil hein et je construis
des guirlandes comme ça voilà que je
vais accrocher sur la fenêtre ou sur la
porte qui peut être autour de la de la
couronne de Noël
des une idée de cadeau de décoration à
reproduire Julien je trouve c'est joli
aux couleurs de Noël déjà autour de la
table parce que peut-être ce type de
décoration peut vous intéresser Régine
décoration zéro déchets
ce genre de décoration donc quand on
peut le faire soi-même c'est mieux quand
même c'est ça
pourrait vous toucher ou d'avoir ce type
de guirlandes c'est une guirlande assez
originale
on est sensibilisé
donc un Noël éco-responsable qui fait
sens en cette période Julien on parle de
plus en plus bien sûr de sobriété
énergétiques vous étiez il y a quelques
jours dans les rues de la ville de la
verrière et la ville a lancé un concours
de Noël un peu particulier cette année
ça et en fait j'ai suivi les six membres
du jury en fait et le concept était très
original cette année puisque il y avait
des contraintes qui étaient imposées aux
habitants et la contrainte c'était la
sobriété énergétique alors l'idée
c'était de limiter au maximum
l'utilisation de décoration électrique
alors même si comme vous pouvez le voir
sur ces images il y avait des guirlandes
électriques chez les participants ils
ont quand même fait l'effort d'utiliser
des ampoules basses consommation et
justement on écoute une membre du jury
et un participant à ce concours les gens
ont plus participé en faisant de la
récupération ils ont mis beaucoup plus
de l'aide et retirer tout ce qui était
énergivores beaucoup plus fait main par
rapport à l'année dernière au niveau de
la décoration de Noël toutes les
ampoules qui étaient incandescentes on
est passé à la LED pour une question
d'économie en plus on a créé aujourd'hui
une horloge pour nous permettre d'avoir
des coupures pour pas que ça reste
allumé toute la nuit je fais pas ça pour
gagner je fais tous les ans je le fais
pour le plaisir de le faire quoi
alors les critères de sélection c'était
l'esthétique générale la densité de la
décoration et l'originalité des idées et
également l'ingéniosité l'ingéniosité
dans la réalisation les résultats du
concours seront connus courant janvier
il faudra un patienter encore quelques
semaines c'est ça merci beaucoup Julien
Laurent on suivra les résultats de ce
concours alors on va passer à un sujet
un peu moins léger maintenant chaque
année plus de 100 000 animaux sont
abandonnés en France avec un pic lors de
la période estivale avec nous pour en
parler Elodie Juillac bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes chef d'équipe de la SPA à
plaisir vous avez combien d'animaux
adopter sur sur ce refuge à plaisir
alors sur le refuge on a à peu près
80-90 chiens et à peu près 150 chats et
5 6 ce qu'on appelle les nacles les
nouveaux animaux de compagnie oui c'est
quoi justement les mecs alors ça
regroupe tout ce qui est rongeurs donc
lapin furet enfin je me ferai un
carnivore mais les lapins les souris les
rats cochon d'inde hamster
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'abandon cet été
comme tous les étés malheureusement
comme depuis deux ans ça s'arrête pas
depuis le covid en fait
on voit même plus de différence entre
l'été et le reste de l'année on est
saturé toute l'année maintenant depuis 2
ans c'est à dire que depuis le covid il
y a un avant et un après il y a
clairement une tendance négative qui qui
se voit depuis le covid
qui ont été adoptés pendant le covid et
puis suite à la reprise du travail qui
n'ont pas été assumées derrière il y a
d'autres explications mis à part le
covid alors ce qui peut remonter aussi
c'est la hausse des prix globale
l'inflation voilà mais sinon non c'est
c'était des effets de mode et les gens
prennent bébé les animaux et puis les
assument pas jusqu'au bout
malheureusement un autre phénomène
au-delà de l'abandon c'est que pendant
la période du covid la stérilisation des
chaînes a pas pu avoir lu en tout cas
elle a été très perturbé oui parler les
chats malheureusement il y a ça se
démultiplie les cliniques vétérinaires
étaient pour beaucoup fermées donc ça a
joué également sur sur les chats alors
au niveau des adoptions est-ce que
inversement enfin vous avez peut-être eu
plus d'adoption ou là aussi c'est ça
reste compliqué alors on a une légère
hausse si on fait par rapport au dernier
années on est une légère au store
forcément puisqu'on était ralenti sur le
covid mais même par rapport à l'année
avant le covid mais très légère qui
compense absolument pas l'effet des Laos
et là encore c'est ça s'explique à cause
de l'inflation les gens on n'a pas les
réels motifs les on a moins de visites
en refuge après oui très clairement rien
a-t-il d'exemple là les croquettes vont
me prendre 15% Gabriel
vous pensez que les gens passaient en
tête toutes les contraintes que ça
implique d'avoir un animal oui
franchement oui il y a beaucoup de
coeurs alors nous on sensibilise
énormément on peut même parfois paraître
dur et restrictif parce que parfois on
se voit refuser des adoptions parce
qu'on est trop dur mais oui on
sensibilise énormément un animal ça vit
très longtemps ça peut avoir des
problèmes de santé ça peut être un
budget et ça demande du temps ça vous
arrive souvent de refuser des adoptions
ça peut
ça peut il y a beaucoup de gens qui
fonctionnent au coup de coeur et
malheureusement on peut pas on peut pas
fonctionner comme ça il faut se projeter
plus loin dans la réflexion
vous vous basez pour
laisser l'adoption ou pas sur les
besoins de l'animal en lui-même c'est à
dire qu'on peut refuser un animal pour
une personne mais lui en proposer un
autre qui correspond mieux à son
contexte de vie donc ça va être bah sur
son hébergement sur les membres de sa
famille sur le temps qu'il a proposé à
l'animal et puis sur le comportement de
l'animal en lui-même
sur l'adoption faire la connaissance
aussi de quelques-uns des animaux qui
sont présents sur ce refuge SPA de
plaisir vous êtes venus en plateau on le
rappelle avec Tyson qu'on a pu voir à
l'image qu'on voit grâce aux images à la
caméra volante de Thomas qui est
également alors vous voyez pas vous avez
eu la régie tout à l'heure mais Thomas
est juste derrière la caméra peut-être
qu'on pourra le voir tout à l'heure sur
sur les plans larges et on parlera oui
aussi de chats aussi qui sont adapté au
refuge SPA de plaisir mais avant tout
cela on va retrouver une nouvelle fois
Michael el midoro qui on le rappelle est
au centre commercial ouest-field Vélizy
2 il prend le pouls à quelques jours des
fêtes de fin d'année une période on
l'imagine de Rush et il le disait avec
son invité il y a quelques instants qui
était le directeur de l'établissement
vous êtes à présent Mickaël avec la
directrice d'une de l'une des enseignes
une enseigne importante qui est présente
sur sur site
effectivement je suis à l'intérieur du
printemps une une enseigne qui est qui
brasse beaucoup de monde pendant ces
périodes de fête je suis avec Agnès
Girard la directrice de cet
établissement alors Agnès Girard est-ce
que c'est un événement important pour
pour votre enseigne Noël alors Noël
c'est l'événement le plus important de
l'année pour nous parce que c'est le
plus festif et c'est là où on rencontre
nos meilleurs clients aussi donc vous
voyez vraiment c'est un vrai rendez-vous
il y a combien de personnes en plus qui
viennent dans votre enseigne chaque jour
pendant Noël alors c'est vraiment le
week-end où on retrouve le plus de
clients et oui on peut avoir jusqu'à 20
000 clients dans la journée donc c'est
beaucoup mais en même temps comme nous
sommes ouverts de 10h à 21h les clients
a le temps de choisir et de faire le
tour du magasin pour trouver le cadeau
parfait parce que c'est ce qu'il
recherche à Noël le cadeau parfait et
quel est le cadeau parfait justement
Agnès je pense que c'est celui qui
correspond le plus à ce que la personne
souhaite et donc il y a pas de cadeau on
va dire qu'on pourrait conseiller
systématiquement à tous les clients
c'est vraiment une recherche une très
bonne connaissance de ce que la personne
recherche on pose beaucoup de questions
avec nos collaborateurs pour vraiment
cibler ce dont on est sûr qui paiera à
la personne parce que ce qui est
important c'est qu'en fait elle se
souvienne du cadeau qu'on lui a fait et
qu'elle se dise oh mais ce cadeau je me
souviens on l'a offert c'était
ma collègue ou mon ami qui m'a offert et
donc c'est ça qui marque et quels sont
les produits justement qui
fonctionne le plus dans votre magasin
alors
bijouterie de fantaisie jusqu'à de la
joaillerie ça c'est vraiment les
produits qui sont le les plus recherchés
et les plus offerts et bien sûr les
incontournables des très jolies gants en
cuir des bonnets des écharpes en plus il
fait froid donc ce sont des très beaux
cadeaux et ils sont utiles le panier
moyen en général ici ça suis vraiment
parce que tout dépend pourquoi le client
est venu soit il est venu pour acheter
des petits cadeaux d'assiette comme on
appelle pour mettre sur la table à Noël
ou alors ils ont pu se grouper et venir
faire un très très beau cadeau donc là
parfois on peut vendre des pièces
d'exception de joaillerie notamment et
est-ce que vous recrutez plus peut-être
pour la période des fêtes
pour être au service de
nos merci beaucoup à Agnès Girard et
vous l'aurez compris il y a beaucoup
plus de monde ici dans ce magasin à
Westfield Vélizy 2 si vous voulez
Grégory Mathilde je peux éventuellement
vous prendre vos cadeaux de Noël en
avance je sais pas à vous de voir on a
compris vous avez fait d'une pierre deux
coups nickel vous allez faire vos
cadeaux de Noël dites-le nous c'est pas
faux c'est pas faux vous me connaissez
bien toujours pas de père Noël à
l'horizon malheureusement
malheureusement toujours pas de père
Noël on a malheureusement bougé de place
donc le Père Noël est resté là où on
était tout à l'heure pour prendre des
photos avec les enfants évidemment le
Père Noël très occupé très occupé en
tout cas merci nickel pour ces points
d'information et vous étiez sur place
avec Patrick Jacques de dixmut pour les
moyens techniques et donc on l'a vu dans
cette émission on vous a donné des idées
de décoration pour le sapin des idées de
cadeaux mais alors je pense que les
Yvelines cherchent aussi à savoir ce
qu'ils vont mettre sur leur table lors
du réveillon et justement à ce propos je
suis allée à la cabane de Grimm pour
filmer la préparation d'une bûche de
Noël je ne sais pas si vous êtes plutôt
sucré ou salé autour du plateau
sucré
voilà à Noël c'est toujours le petit
mais classique à mettre sur la table et
ben pour les pour les gourmands qui sont
plutôt sucrés je vous propose de
regarder la bûche de Noël concoctée par
la cabane de Grimm à Houdan
bonjour
Cécile Lefrançois Gomet je suis
dirigeante de la cabane de Grimm et
artisan chocolatier glacier que je vous
propose là c'est de vous présenter le
montage d'une bûche phare que l'on a
cette année qui est la bûche Galaxy
puisque toutes nos pièces tournent
autour du thème un Noël dans l'espace
cette année
à vous propose de monter cette bûche on
va commencer par turbiner le sorbet
ananas j'ai déjà préparé à l'avance un
insert sorbet mangue passion que je vais
recouvrir de chocolat c'est parti on va
mixer émulsionner la glace avant de la
mettre en turbine voilà ça permet de
bien lier les éléments entre eux pour
avoir une glace la plus onctueuse
possible et on va verser ça dans la
turbine
voilà et on en a pour une petite
vingtaine de minutes
[Musique]
alors là maintenant ce qu'on va faire
c'est préparer le l'enrobage de notre
bûche
[Musique]
alors là on va sortir la glace de la
turbine
[Musique]
je récupère mon insert
faites le montage d'une bûche se fait à
l'envers
[Musique]
alors là nous allons démouler notre
bûche maintenant qu'elle a bien refroidi
[Musique]
voilà je nous avons réalisé ensemble la
bûche Galaxy je vous souhaite de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]
alors est-ce que ça vous donne envie de
goûter autour du plateau c'est vrai que
ça met l'eau à la bouche
Gabriel j'étais avec vous pour tourner
cette recette mais oui effectivement ça
a l'air très très bon effectivement
[Musique]
et bien on va continuer de parler avec
vous Elodie Julien qu'on le rappelle
vous êtes avec nous en plateau et avec
Tyson qui est à croiser Basset assez
musclé on le présentait un petit peu
tout à l'heure et on voulait aussi
donner l'idée spectateurs d'offrir un
beau Noël au animaux abandonnés vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'adoption qui
est une adoption responsable c'est euh
se met ce que met en avant la SPA c'est
un acte qui n'est pas anodin la SPA dit
que les animaux ne sont finalement pas
des cadeaux à offrir à Noël c'est quand
même un acte beaucoup plus réfléchi qui
doit être pris avec avec du sérieux
c'est ce que vous commenciez à expliquer
tout à l'heure c'est ça déjà il faut que
les gens soient là on offre pas un
animal il faut que les gens les
sélectionnent je repense juste à un
refuge qui vient de recevoir un abandon
d'un chiot qui a été offert pour Noël à
l'instant le côté cadeau de Noël c'est
un côté un peu impulsif finalement les
gens ne veulent pas forcément un animal
en fait donc il faut laisser les gens
choisir et lequel voilà il y a des
questions à se poser forcément avant
l'adoption bien sûr bah le c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure la finance le
temps
ça demande du temps en animal et ça peut
avoir des des soucis de santé donc voilà
c'est sa vie sur le long terme donc
c'est pas à prendre à la légère est-ce
que c'est important aussi d'en parler à
tous ses proches les proches du foyer
qui vont accueillir cette animal c'est
important d'avoir une discussion tous
ensemble alors nous dans tous les cas on
demande à ce que tous les membres du
foyer soient présents les enfants et
tous les adultes voilà pour que le
contact se fasse avec l'animal et que
tout le monde valide l'avenue de cet
animal au foyer il faut que le lien soit
fait avec tout le monde je suis là et
puis des fois lorsqu'on voit les enfants
on s'aperçoit que l'enfant a très peur
de l'animal tout simplement ou que le
mari lorsque la dame arrive au foyer
avec l'animal il n'était pas en fait pas
d'accord donc maintenant on exige que
tout le monde soit là
il commence à se passe concrètement pour
pour adopter vous en parler aussi tout à
l'heure pour un téléspectateur qui
souhaiterait entrer dans une démarche
d'adoption et bien il vient au refuge et
on va lui faire compléter un petit
formulaire de questions pour nous
décrire son mode de vie et puis après il
va pouvoir aller voir les animaux et
discuter avec des agents animaliers qui
pourront conseiller sur l'animal qui
pourrait le correspondre le mieux et
après bien sûr on fait une rencontre et
puis c'est tout se passe bien il repart
avec donc pour faire la connaissance des
animaux au refuge SPA de plaisir on le
disait Tyson qui est avec nous qui est
un mal de trois ans vous commenciez à
nous en parler tout à l'heure pour nous
présenter quel est son histoire à Tyson
il nous a été abandonné au refuge par
ses anciens maîtres après il a été
adopté deux fois et malheureusement il
n'arrive pas à s'habituer à la vie
urbaine notamment avec les enfants on
pense qu'il a déjà été embêté par des
enfants et du coup il les supporte
absolument pu donc maintenant son
prochain placement ça va être dans une
maison à la campagne voilà sans enfant
et ils s'entend très bien avec les
autres chiens par contre ça fait combien
de temps que que vous l'avez dans votre
fiche du coup on l'a depuis février donc
il va on a une break il ne fait pas
c'est un an au refuge voilà
pas forcément avec des enfants mais en
tout cas il est très câlin c'est ce
qu'on a remarqué aussi en rédaction il
est venu il est venu vers nous avant
l'émission et voilà là bon il est
positif il est monté sur la table mais
ouais c'est quelqu'un c'est c'est un
animal très affectueux ouais très
affectueux très attachant qui protégera
sa famille donc il faut évidemment pas
trop recevoir parce que il est pas fan
des invités au foyer il est gardien
voilà mais sinon oui il sera très
affectueux
effrayant des soirées dans le canapé à
côté de sa maîtresse oui il a déjà
adopté le canapé en loge tout à l'heure
il est monté dessus Isma l'aise tout à
fait on va faire la connaissance
d'autres animaux alors il y a un autre
chien mal qui s'appelle wrap qui a 5 ans
on va voir les différentes d'identité si
je puis dire s'afficher alors là c'est
celle de Tyson qu'on a bien sûr en
plateau et voilà wrap qui est aussi un
mâle et qui a du coup lui 5 ans 5 ans
qui a plus de deux ans de refuge
voilà donc wrap c'est un gentil chien
mais qui est hyperactif donc qui
demandera beaucoup de dépenses physiques
et puis des petits exercices
intellectuels aussi c'est un croisé
malinois
pour pareil une vie à la campagne et
sans autre animaux vous avez aussi une
femelle à présent qui s'appelle Isis
elle a 7 ans voilà alors easy cell c'est
une chienne qui
voilà c'est une cane corso qui vivait
sur un balcon
et voilà qui a qui est pas en bon état
de santé et on aimerait qu'elle ne
termine pas ces jours au refuge donc là
ça devient urgent qu'elle parte parce
que elle se dégrade au refuge elle ne
supporte plus le refuge c'est une
gentille hygiène qui a juste besoin
d'une maison et d'un
jardinier aussi vous êtes
est devenu nous parler de deux chats il
y a craquette qui est une une femelle
voilà on la voit de une femelle de 1 an
voilà craquette alors krakette elle a
son petit caractère c'est une chatte
qu'il faudra respecter c'est à dire que
c'est elle qui décide quand il y a des
câlins si elle en veut pas on force pas
et qui a une alimentation spécifique
puisqu'elle mange et croquettes rénale
voilà mais sinon il y a aussi un mâle
qui s'appelle couteau il a deux en lui
alors couteau oui c'est un gros mal
alors on voit pas beaucoup sur la photo
mais il a des énormes joues et couteau
sa particularité c'est qu'il est
positif il a le sida du chat donc il
devra vivre en appartement il ne pourra
pas aller à l'extérieur et il déteste
les autres chats donc et les chiens
voilà donc sans autre animaux
sur le sujet
tout ce que ça englobe d'avoir un animal
mais il faut penser à tous les critères
pensez à tous les critères et on disait
avec Elodie Julia que c'est un acte
réfléchi un acte qui n'est pas anodin en
tout cas si vous voulez un peu plus
d'informations bien sûr sur sur
l'adoption sur la SPA vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
site Internet de la SPA qui va
s'afficher et qui s'affiche actuellement
en bas de l'écran merci Elodie et Julia
qui d'être venu avec Tyson en plateau en
remercie Tyson également d'être venu et
je rappelle que vous êtes la chef
d'équipe chef d'équipe à la SPA de
plaisir merci à vous on vous garde un
tout petit peu puisqu'on va on va tester
avec vous plusieurs idées de cadeaux à
glisser sous le sapin pour nos animaux
domestiques à Tiz barré vous êtes venus
avec plusieurs idées on commence par les
chats oui alors effectivement il faut
penser également à nos animaux pendant
les fêtes il nous accompagnent toute
l'année ça fait partie de ce sont des
membres de notre famille également qu'il
faut choyer et chouchouter donc j'ai
pensé d'abord à au petit sapin de de
Noël vraiment petit voilà on va planter
le sapin de Noël pour nos amis des chats
et en réalité ce n'est pas simplement
assez sympa c'est un griffoir un
griffoir pour les chats donc il y a des
petites boules voilà comme ça le chapeau
fait du bruit ça fait du bruit ça
pourrait l'amuser il y a également de
l'herbe à l'intérieur je vous rassure de
l'herbe à chat donc il pourra s'amuser
avec
voilà on pourra mettre autour et puis
donc le chat sera tranquille auprès de
son petit sapin et ce qui m'a beaucoup
plu dans ce sapin on parlait de
d'écologie donc c'est un sapin en papier
qui pourrait être recyclable là j'ai
trouvé ce modèle là chez animalis
ensuite nous avons donc un petit repas
également un petit repas de luxe pour
nos chats donc on a des lamelles on aura
donc des lamelles au saumon donc ça
c'est un coffret de Rosewood donc
lamelles il y a également des lamelles
au poulet du haut poulet fromage
qui est en face de nous Thomas voilà qui
sont très bons j'ai le saumon c'est
celui que j'ai beaucoup apprécié à
sentir je pense que ils vont beaucoup
aimer donc des lamelles voilà elles sont
très fines il y a un sachet à
l'intérieur c'est un sachet pour
conserver ne surtout pas donner à vos
chats et voilà les petites lamelles
voilà pour nos chats
alors pour les donc ça c'était pour les
chats pour les chiens comme comme Tyson
comme comme les autres est-ce que vous
avez également des idées à nous donner
bien sûr donc pour
Tyson
on a notre
coussin notre coussin chauffant on a
parlé en plus de problèmes d'économie
d'énergie donc là on a un coussin qui
est relaxe thermique donc qui est auto
chauffant donc ça va permettre
d'économiser de l'énergie donc le chien
va se poser dessus et en même temps il
se met en mode en mode plaid voilà
agréable
je pense que ça va plaire à Tyson vous
me disez tout à l'heure qu'il aimait
bien les soirées canapés
[Rires]
ensuite une petite peluche pain d'épices
mais ce n'est pas simplement une peluche
c'est il y a des cordes au bout donc ça
c'est un cadeau pour Tyson qui ne
repartira pas du plateau les pâtes vides
voilà et donc il fait elle fait du bruit
on fera tester à Tyson
et alors pour les pour les rongeurs on
les oublie
un autre petit cadeau pour pour les
chiens on va faire tester à Tyson
un pâté pâté donc à la dinde avec donc
pâté de dinde avec du panais des
carottes donc si vous le permettez je
vais le faire tester à Tyson qui va nous
dire lui-même
un petit repas
voilà son petit repas
franchement c'est ça qui fait coin coin
tout à l'heure
l'intervention de Nicolas
en attendant tester le jouet avec Tyson
à c'est validé
on fera goûter à Tyson tout à l'heure
vous vouliez nous parler aussi des idées
de cadeaux pour pour nos amis les
rongeurs et oui un autre sapin donc pour
nos amis les rongeurs donc c'est un
sapin où on va cacher de la nourriture à
l'intérieur donc parce que nos amis
rongeurs sont très très curieux donc
pour fouiner donc on va cacher la
nourriture en parlant de nourriture donc
on a également un petit panier avec du
foin
avec des cookies
des cookies en forme de sapin
donc des cookies qui sont complets et
très bons pour leur santé je peux même
vous en offrir un pour le thé ça passera
bien parce qu'ils sont vraiment
équilibrés et complet voilà
je vais le montrer à la caméra le petit
cœur qu'on a vu il y a un instant
ça peut être aussi pour tous les animaux
donc quand on a du mal à faire des
selfies donc on pose son téléphone et
puis on fait un selfie
et je vous propose de faire un selfie
tous ensemble
voilà
alors on regarde tous
la balle on regarde la balle
merci beaucoup à this pour toutes ces
idées alors je sais pas si vous deviez
rendre ces cadeaux mais je
pense que Tyson a bien compris il a bien
aimé le jouet
nous avons été rejoints en plateau par
Nicolas
ustache bonsoir alors vous êtes le
responsable marketing et communication
de Versailles Château spectacle château
de Versailles spectacle vous allez nous
parler d'un spectacle qui a lieu et qui
a déjà commencé et qui va se terminer au
mois de janvier tout à fait le parcours
du roi donc qui a commencé juste samedi
dernier et qui a lieu d'ailleurs ce soir
en ce moment même qui est un parcours en
fait déambulatoire dans les plus belles
salles et plus beaux appartements du
château c'est une nouvelle manière en
fait de découvrir ce patrimoine on a la
chance d'avoir dans les Yvelines avec en
plus c'est ça le bonus cet événement
tout le savoir-faire baroque des
artistes du château de Versailles donc
on pense notamment à des chanteurs
lyriques on pense à des danseurs des
magiciens
des escrimeurs parce qu'on essayait
vraiment de reconstituer le temps de
cette soirée tous les talents et les
arts de l'époque voilà donc c'est en ce
moment même dans notre château que vous
connaissez bien je crois et ce n'est pas
votre premier édition ça fait déjà
plusieurs fois que que vous faites ce
spectacle ça fait en effet maintenant
trois éditions qu'on présente cet
événement au château de Versailles et
grâce au succès des années précédentes
on a la chance maintenant d'avoir une
programmation encore plus plus vaste en
termes de date donc il faut profiter
c'est en effet jusqu'au 1er janvier et
c'était maintenant est-ce qu'il y a
quelques quelques changements par
rapport à l'édition de l'année dernière
ou ça reste globalement pareil tout a
changé d'accord je vous rassure on a
toujours pas changé les salles du
château mais en tout cas pour tout ce
qui est artistique tous les artistes qui
interviennent ont tous changé en fait
dans la programmation on a la chance
d'avoir monté l'Académie de danse
baroque à l'Opéra Royal de Versailles et
c'est maintenant nos artistes qui
viennent présenter leurs
œuvres et leur tout le long de cet
événement qui a une programmation tout
au long de l'année il y a des classiques
on pense forcément aux grandes eaux
fonctionne l'été et là forcément c'est
aussi un rendez-vous classique alors oui
qui maintenant se déroule depuis
plusieurs années oui exactement c'est un
nouveau rendez-vous de la période des
vacances de Noël et donc on a la chance
voilà d'en profiter il y a aussi
d'autres rendez-vous qui ponctuent cette
saison hivernage notamment de très beaux
spectacles on a un concert à l'Opéra de
de charpentier Noël baroque qui a lieu
le 16 et 2 autres concerts qui ont lieu
avec le Messie joué par fadjolic est un
nouveau grand chef de musical voilà je
vous invite à venir découvrir les 17 et
18 décembre et alors je crois à la fin
du spectacle le parcours du roi il y a
un invité surprise mais ce qu'on va tout
dire
bon peut-être qu'il faut pas tout
dévoiler effectivement
il y a un invité surprise que les
enfants connaissent très très bien pour
les enfants on l'appelle le Père Noël
baroque parce que évidemment il est un
peu différent du Père Noël traditionnel
et il est dans la galerie des Batailles
et cette magnifique galerie en fin de
visite du château et là où tous les
enfants ont la chance d'aller la sa
rencontre et de prendre quelques photos
on n'a pas eu la chance nous de
l'accueillir en plateau mais il y a le
Père Noël baroque il est occupé le
neutre en tout cas est actuellement est
actuellement au château un petit tour
vous êtes déjà allé au château de
Versailles c'est quand même voilà c'est
quand même le monument quand on pense
aux Yvelines et au tourisme on pense
d'abord à cet événement ça vous donne
envie d'y aller oui complètement ça
marche pour les grands hein
on parlait des enfants oui on parle des
enfants
il faut venir au parcours du roi je
crois que Nicolas
ah oui Nicolas dandry tout à l'heure je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi parce que
alors Tyson il parle
bien sûr
voilà pour le quiz naturel
merci voilà il avait mordu et mordu
l'oreille bah c'est peut-être déjà le
l'occasion aussi de dire au revoir à
Tyson et le 10 juillet que je sais qui
est très pressé mais qui nous a fait le
plaisir de venir en plateau merci
beaucoup d'être venu avec Tyson merci
merci à vous et on va vous laisser
tranquillement quitter le plateau et
vous souhaitez bien sûr de joyeuses
fêtes de fin d'année pas de souci merci
à vous et puis bonne fête merci
alors c'est vrai qu'à Noël on a parlé il
y avait la bûche mais il y a également
les apéritifs
quelques questions pratiques pour venir
sur voilà on enchaîne voilà c'est de
l'improvisation voilà c'est c'est le
direct peut-être quelques infos
pratiques pour pour venir sur quel jour
peut-on venir comment faut-il s'y
prendre est-ce qu'il faut réserver sa
place à l'avance et il est vivement
conseillé de louer comme on peut dire
c'est en vente sur notre site château de
Versailles qui respectent le point FR et
on a déjà vendu énormément de billets
donc impossible de réserver sa place
pour ce week-end c'est déjà complet donc
je vous invite vraiment à réserver de
manière assez rapide si vous voulez
profiter de cette magnifique expérience
merci beaucoup d'être venu en parler
avec plaisir merci beaucoup Nicolas
merci
ça y est
je sais voilà on aime parler de Google
Gabriel voilà j'avais oublié son prénom
elle s'appelle Gabriel nous le rappelle
souvent dans les émissions du 7 8 qu'on
aime tout ce qui est après la
gastronomie on va parler d'idées de
choses à mettre l'idée de choses plutôt
pour l'apéritif pour l'apéritif
des idées certains journalistes se sont
rendus à 20 et saveurs au salon 20 et
saveurs de Poissy et on y trouvait
plusieurs produits plusieurs produits
locaux comme des vins des bières ou
encore des biscuits régénérés vous nous
avez concocté plusieurs une petite
sélection exactement et parmi leurs
trouvailles une épicerie que l'on nomme
les deux gourmands cette épicerie c'est
au départ l'histoire de Louis et de
Guillaume deux amis passionnés par la
gastronomie et l'agriculture tous deux
ont décidé de créer des biscuits
composés de produits locaux et propose
également du pain du pain d'épices
pardon des bonbons et du miel de région
on écoute Marie Le Pelletier une des
collaboratrices qui nous donne ces
indispensables pour Noël au micro de
Michael el midoro alors le pain d'épice
évidemment si vous avez du foie gras et
que notre pain d'épice c'est voilà
excellent
et après si vous voulez faire des
petites sauces au miel évidemment et
puis nos biscuits apéro pour l'apéro
en cette saison on a une bière de Noël
donc une bière de Noël on produit à peu
près 1000 litres par an et donc ceux qui
ont la chance de la boire c'est des
privilégiés on peut dire on rappellera
bien sûr Régine que l'alcool est à
consommer avec modération exactement
mais pour terminer je vous propose tout
de même de découvrir la bouche du roi
une marque de vin fondée en 2017 et
dessiné à faire revivre le vignoble
francilien situé en pleine de Versailles
à d'Avron les vignes sont cultivées sans
pestifs sans pesticides Bastien aussi
l'un des fondateurs de la marque nous
conseille quelques vins pour accompagner
vos plats en l'écoute je vous conseille
le chenin en entrée avec les huîtres ou
fruits de mer si jamais vous avez la
chance dans dans déguster pendant les
fêtes et ensuite
je dirais moi mon préféré c'est le pinot
noir en rouge sinon un assemblage merlot
cabernet franc il y avait parfaitement
avec une dinde ou les plats habituels
les fêtes de Noël
alors merci beaucoup Régine relève pour
toutes ces idées de cadeaux qu'est-ce
qui vous donne le plus envie autour du
plateau un peu tout
autour de la gastronomie en général
c'est dans local
à consommer avec ma direction
c'est des saveurs
complètement différentes on y sent le
coeur qui a été mis dedans donc là
c'était des idées de produits à mettre
sur la table de Noël vous ne parlerez
tout à l'heure d'idées plutôt de cadeaux
des cadeaux yvinois aussi à faire pour
pour nos proches ou pour d'autres
personnes à l'occasion des fêtes de fin
d'année on va rester quand même dans le
thème gastronomique on est gourmand on
le rappelle on le rappelle encore une
nouvelle fois Mathilde je crois que vous
avez testé après donc tout à l'heure
vous voyez la bûche vous avez testé
aussi à fabrication du pain d'épices oui
tout à fait avec Gabriel on est allé
faire des décorations sur des pains
d'épices alors c'était pas si facile que
ça Grégory on a eu un peu de mal quand
même c'est la décoration pas la
fabrication la décoration et puis
assemblage bah je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder le reportage
[Musique]
et je me trouve justement avec Aurélie
sulpizio pour confectionner mon propre
pain d'épices alors Aurélie on commence
par quoi alors nous on a fait les
maisons au préalable avant votre arrivée
donc une pâte à pain d'épices ou dans un
batteur on va mélanger la farine la
levure les œufs et un mélange d'épices
avec de la cannelle de la misère de la
badiane et d'autres que je ne citerai
pas
et là on va s'attaquer aux décorations
des petites maisons super bah je vais
essayer de pas faire n'importe quoi vous
allez me conseiller facile
vous avez déjà tenu une poche à douille
[Musique]
[Rires]
on a fait des couleurs c'est de la glace
royale ça s'appelle c'est un mélange de
blanc d'oeuf de sucre glace avec un
zeste de citron auquel on ajoute du
colorant naturel
[Musique]
pour faire ma première fois c'est normal
c'est pas mal
ça fait un peu pain d'épice d'enfants
quand même je pense que la première fois
que j'en ai fait je devais être pire que
vous
[Musique]
maintenant qu'on a fini on va passer au
montage de la maison on va faire un
cornet de chocolat blanc qu'on a et
c'est ce qui va nous servir de colle
justement
[Musique]
bon ben elles sont pas mal nos maisons
quand même
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Aurélie plusieurs pour
tous vos conseils de rien maintenant nos
téléspectateurs peuvent faire leurs
propres plantes d'épices et décorer leur
propre pain de pistolet
spécial fin d'année toute la rédaction
de tv70 toute la chaîne de tv70ité et
mobilisé pour vous faire vivre cette fin
d'année vous donner des idées à
l'approche des fêtes et justement Julien
avec vous on voit quelques idées comment
passer à Noël plus éco-responsable avec
quelques bons conseils à donner à noter
les spectateurs tout au long de cette
édition c'est ça tout à l'heure on a vu
la fameuse guirlande en agrume là
maintenant anna va donner quelques
conseils de d'idées cadeaux zéro déchet
alors là on va voir des jeux de
sensibilisation au zéro déchet ou des
cadeaux cosmétiques lavables regardez ça
plutôt
[Musique]
alors un peu plus classieux que
l'emballage crépon on a aussi
l'emballage que les Japonais ça c'est un
art traditionnel japonais appelle le
furoshik donc cette emballage il va
utiliser en fait un textile un tissu
donc moi je trouve que j'ai pris ce que
j'ai trouvé en fait une belle soie dont
le dessin me plaisait les couleurs la
dimension elle est grande elle est
probablement très grande mais ça après
quand vous allez dans les magasins
spécialisés vous trouverez votre bonheur
le principe reste le même dans tous les
cas donc c'est ça le plus important je
place mon carré bien à plat et je me
mets dans une diagonale
ici j'ai la diagonale
et je vais placer mon cadeau aligné vous
voyez le bord aligné avec la diagonale
et là
je coince mon tissu sous le cadeau
et je vais aller chercher l'autre coin
je fais un tour
et je ramène
c'est le même principe que le papier
cadeau en fin de compte et là je fais
mon nœud alors c'est un nœud plat un
nœud plat c'est un nœud de lacet
voilà là mon cadeau voyez l'emballage il
tient et comme ça vous voyez que sous le
sapin on a quelque chose de très joli
dans la tradition japonaise je repars
avec le tissu donc l'emballage n'est pas
le cadeau faites la personne je lui
laisse le cadeau et du coup il n'y a pas
d'emballage et moi ce tissu je vais
pouvoir l'utiliser pour emballer tous
les cadeaux que je veux je le récupère à
chaque fois bien évidemment si vous
voulez l'offrir c'est un très beau
cadeau en même temps
bon alors c'est pas l'idée de cadeau
qu'on a vu on la verra dans quelques
instants rassurer rassurez-vous et
rassurer on va rassurer nos noter le
spectateurs là c'était plutôt
l'emballage est-ce que vous ça vous est
déjà arrivé vous de prendre je sais pas
moi des feuilles de papier journal par
exemple pour pour faire vos emballages
cadeaux de prendre des choses un peu
différentes je sais pas Régine non
malheureusement
mais ça m'est jamais venu à l'idée mais
du coup pourquoi pas non ça m'est jamais
arrivé non plus mais c'est une bonne
idée je trouve et là c'est vrai que
c'était une autre idée moi c'est vrai
que je pense tout de suite au papier
journal les journalistes voilà donc on
pense tout de suite à la presse mais
effectivement c'était une belle idée à
10 ça m'est arrivé très souvent même de
faire des cornets avec le papier et puis
de mettre des PIPA seul à l'intérieur
avec des foulards également ça me va
beaucoup arriver mais moi aussi par
manque de papier cadeau ça m'est arrivé
des fois ça sauve la vie moi j'avoue que
sur les cadeaux de Noël qu'on se fait
entre entre journalistes et entre
salarié TV 70 on fait le secret de Santa
chaque année ça m'est déjà arrivé de
prendre effectivement une feuille de
papier journal Le Parisien voilà pour
citer nos confrères qu'on lit beaucoup
dans la rédaction pour effectivement
agrémenter ses cadeaux mais on verra
tout à l'heure une idée de cadeau vers à
les cadeaux tout à l'heure ouais voilà
reste resté avec nous pour savoir en
savoir un peu plus Grégory je crois que
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué que vous
aviez déjà commencé vos idées de cadeaux
oui tout à fait bah je me suis déjà
rendu dans quelques boutiques les
cadeaux sont pas tout à fait terminés
mais on est en bonne voie il nous reste
un petit peu de temps avant Noël est-ce
que autour du plateau vous avez
également commencé vos cadeaux de Noël
ou pas encore
c'est la catastrophe ici aussi
j'ai commencé mes cadeaux et puis j'ai
commencé à faire la demande aussi pour
mes propres cadeaux aussi pour faciliter
l'attache qu'on faisait aussi l'enfant
au Père Noël voilà comme ça c'est plus
simple vous avez raison au moins c'est
plus simple bravo en tout cas si si vous
ne savez toujours pas quoi offrir vous
pouvez vous offrir des cadeaux locaux
avec des artisans Yvelines noires Régine
vous en avez sélectionné quelques-uns on
vit et pour égaler les fans d'histoire
et de senteurs je vous propose de
découvrir la marque og elle se situe à
Montainville et c'est la créatrice
Pascale OGE qui a voulu redonner vie à
des parfums des senteurs et même des
objets ayant appartenu à des célèbres
personnages français elle propose donc
une gamme de bougies et de parfum
d'intérieur d'époque je vous propose d'y
jeter un œil
la gamme c'est le parfum du domaine de
Madame Élisabeth le parfum Madame
Elisabeth qui existe en bougie et un
parfum d'intérieur c'est un parfum en
fait qui a été dédié qui a été rattaché
au domaine de Madame Élisabeth il
reprend trois huiles essentielles très
caractéristiques du XVIIIe siècle la
fleur d'oranger la rose de Damas et le
tilleul
et pour pimenter votre réveillon de Noël
je vous propose un cadeau très original
une sauce piquante made in Viroflay
cette sauce est l'initiative de la
famille Martin qui voudrait mettre à mal
une légende qui insinuerait que les
Français n'aiment pas le piment les
créateurs de la marque Anna
Jean-Baptiste et Benjamin ont donc cocu
concocté des sauces qui je suis qui je
cite promettrait de mettre le feu au
sapin je vous laisse regarder et une
chose qu'à base de piment à bannero il
est fermenté pendant à peu près deux ans
en fût et après on cuisine les sauces et
alors là vous avez ça en bouche vous
avez quelque chose d'extraordinaire de
fruité et de brûlant à souhait vous
mettez ça sous le sapin et vous allez
mettre le feu au sapin
et donc on le voit ils sont également
déguisés en piment c'était une volonté
de c'était sa volonté mais moi justement
j'ai une question vous êtes plutôt qu'en
douceur parfum bougie ou plutôt vous
êtes attiré par les saveurs un peu
piquantes
alors moi le piment
on va pimenter le réveillon j'ai pas la
sauce piquante en tête mais bon ouais
mais pourquoi pas c'est une idée
originale avec plusieurs gammes et en
plus oui une sauce locale c'est ça aussi
mais c'est très intéressant mais moi je
vous propose de mettre un peu des pistes
voilà on va ouvrir dans votre maison des
pistes un petit peu mais pas trop quand
même pas trop
alors pour les fêtes il y a aussi toute
une chaîne de solidarité qui se met en
place on peut citer quelques opérations
chaque année celle du Père Noël vert du
Secours populaire qui vient en aide aux
jeunes aux familles aux enfants
également aux personnes âgées ou isolées
pour leur permettre de fêter Noël et la
nouvelle année avec dignité c'est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres il y en a
également un qu'on va mettre en avant
que vous avez mis en avant justement
Régine ralech avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmut c'est celui de l'association rire
78 qui a une nouvelle fois organisé son
spectacle qui était à destination des
enfants hospitalisés du centre
hospitalier de Versailles constitue au
Chesnay au concours au programme une
version moderne du petit chaperon rouge
sous forme de comédie musicale suivie
d'un goûter et je vous propose de
regarder justement votre reportage
[Musique]
je ne la croque pas de la musique des
rires et des histoires une recette que
les petits adorent chaque année le
Centre Hospitalier de Versailles propose
un spectacle aux enfants malades ou
hospitalisés cet après-midi là sous les
feux des projecteurs c'est le petit
chaperon rouge qui est mis en scène
j'attendais ça depuis quelques jours
pour quand on a reçu l'invitation
j'étais très content de recevoir un
cadeau de voir un spectacle d'avoir un
goûter c'est très bien avec l'hôpital
face à avec l'attaque cyberata quand
même c'est très bien une initiative de
rire 78 l'association rocancourtoise
veut propager la joie dans les Yvelines
rire pour guérir est une de leurs
actions elle propose des moments
divertissants pour les enfants
hospitalisés
rendez-vous qui est très important pour
les enfants pour les enfants et pour
leur famille d'ailleurs pas seulement
pour les enfants parce que c'est un
temps de réunion un petit peu en dehors
de la maladie dans le contexte quand
même de l'hôpital c'est ils viennent
voir le spectacle de l'hôpital mais ils
viennent pas pour une consultation donc
on les voit de manière très plaisante il
y a pas de verdict il y a pas de choses
désagréables attendues au des cours
l'association nous a commandé le
spectacle parce que on joue beaucoup
dans les écoles mais c'est vrai que
jouer aussi pour des enfants qui sont
voilà qui sont suivis à l'hôpital c'est
voilà c'est hyper important leur
apporter un petit peu de voilà un peu de
baume au coeur un peu de un peu de Noël
un peu de joie c'est enfin c'est
vraiment on est on est vraiment ravis de
jouer pour eux aujourd'hui à ce jour 117
spectacles ont été présentés dans 23
hôpitaux et cliniques des Yvelines
alors je sais qu'à l'approche des fêtes
de fin d'année certains aiment bien
regarder ou regarder des films des
feuilletons de Noël Grégory est-ce que
vous avez un feuilleton que vous
regardez chaque année à Noël alors les
feuilles tournoi en général ceux qui
passent à la télé ça je déteste
personnellement parce que je trouve
c'est toujours la même histoire un peu
toujours les mêmes personnages les mêmes
intrigues après l'approche demain il y a
les classiques moi j'aime bien me
refaire les les films de Disney il y a
beaucoup de classiques alors chose un
peu plus insolite les films aussi les
vieux films les films de gangster moi je
suis très très fan le parrain rien à
voir avec le parrain avec Noël donc il y
a le parrain forcément de Francis Ford
Coppola Scarface également les
affranchis voilà j'aime tous ces vieux
films avec Robert De Niro Al Pacino
c'est des acteurs moi qui me plaisent et
c'est vrai que c'est des films sur un
format long et à Noël on a un peu plus
de temps pour pour les redécouvrir à
nouveau moi je suis plus adepte des
Disney je sais que souvent à Noël je
regarde le Disney et Elizabeth Elisabeth
La Belle et la Bête 2 qui est en rapport
avec avec Noël est-ce que autour de la
table vous avez un petit dessin animé ou
un film que vous regardez
moi j'ai bien aimé Le journal de Bridget
Jones voilà c'était drôle et oui bah les
classiques Maman j'ai raté l'avion mais
sinon c'est vrai que je suis pas non
plus une grande adepte des des feuilles
tombes qui sont passées à la télé
pendant cette période
chocolaterie aussi voilà des petits
classiques de Noël
moi j'assume moi je suis une adepte des
feuilles tombent
travaux d'Astérix le lait c'est passé à
538 celui-là je peux le regarder
plusieurs fois Nicolas
depuis le début c'est un peu notre
humoriste on a parlé du monde avec cette
troupe rire 70 cette association qui
redonne le sourire aux enfants que vous
nous redonnez aussi le sourire en
plateau vous essayez en tout cas
j'essaye les films de Noël est-ce que ça
vous plaît est-ce que il y en a certains
que vous refaisez peut-être ce que vous
revisionnez au moment des fêtes je vais
rejoindre beaucoup de personnes autour
du plateau Disney forcément les films de
Disney pas en particulier par contre je
vois à quoi vous faisiez vous faites
référence ATIS c'est vrai que se laisser
passer combien déjà je sais plus un sens
à 538 dans les douze travaux d'Astérix
et on aurait pu demander à notre
journaliste un peu spécialiste ciné elle
a un petit peu cette étiquette depuis le
début de l'année c'est Céline Charles
alors en régie peut-être qu'on va
pouvoir la voir sur la caméra en régie
je sais pas si elle est toujours
branchée cette caméra en régie peut-être
qu'elle pourra nous faire un coucou non
elle est cachée elle est cachée voilà on
voit juste sa petite main qui qui
apparaît qui aurait pu aussi nous dire
ces films de Noël mais on va parler de
films justement avec un spécialiste de
Noël avec Vincent Mirabel plus
exactement qui lui aussi a une idée
plutôt insolite il vous propose un film
d'horreur sur Noël je vous propose de
regarder
[Musique]
c'est bientôt Noël et pourquoi pour une
fois ne pas changer de registre
cinématographique on a vu 100 fois la
vie est belle magnifique film de Franck
Capra mais cette fois-ci je vous propose
de partir dans un genre de film de
frissons australien très peu connu watch
out de Chris pekover film de 2016 qui
est un mélange de Maman j'ai raté
l'avion et de Scream autrement dit un
film original qui réussit à raconter
l'histoire d'une jolie jeune baby-sitter
qui doit garder un jeune homme de 12 ans
tout se passe bien c'est le soir de Noël
il y a plein de réjouissances en vue
mais deux malfrats vont tenté de
s'introduire dans la maison et là les
choses vont basculer
ce qui est formidable dans ce film ce
sont les rebondissements constants et
les surprises ça n'est pas un film à
mettre devant tous les yeux mais c'est
un film riche en surprise il est
australien et donc il pousse parfois un
peu plus loin la violence que les
Américains néanmoins le scénario est
absolument remarquable on ne s'ennuie
pas une seconde et vous verrez à la fin
un coup de théâtre extraordinaire ce
film là passe notamment par le fait que
les deux malfrats ne sont pas le plus
grand danger car parfois le danger est à
l'intérieur de la maison une succession
de montagnes russes émotionnelle et au
final un vrai film de Noël puisqu'il y a
une vraie surprise mais celle-ci on ne
l'attend pas depuis 2000 ans
[Musique]
bon ce sera pas pour moi moi j'aime pas
trop les films d'horreur même si c'est
bon voilà il y a un petit peu de
d'esprit Noël un tout petit peu quand
même dans le film et on remercie bien
sûr Vincent Mirabel qu'on retrouve à
nombreuses reprises tout au long de
l'année dans le 7 8 il nous livre avec
d'autres réalisateurs et Vinois d'autres
spécialistes du cinéma dans les Yvelines
les coups de cœur pour redécouvrir des
classiques du cinéma chez soi
tranquillement installé dans son canapé
on va vous retrouver une dernière fois
Julien alors oui tout à l'heure il y a
eu un petitproco vous avez parlé d'une
idée de cadeau finalement c'est plutôt
l'idée d'emballage on a vu dans
l'emballage voilà on a vu cette idée
d'emballage zéro déchet alors dans
l'emballage cadeau il y a bien sûr un
cadeau
on va regarder quelques idées du coup de
cadeaux zéro déchet donc on en parlait
tout à l'heure des jeux de
sensibilisation au zéro déchet ou des
cadeaux cosmétiques la on regarde tout
de suite Anna c'est parti
[Musique]
la famille presque zéro déchet alors
celle-ci je l'aime beaucoup parce que
justement elle a la particularité d'être
vous voyez dans ce message de tolérance
c'est un objectif il faut pas se dire si
j'y arrive pas c'est foutu en fait c'est
un pas après l'autre qu'on apprend à
marcher là vous avez un plateau donc
c'est un très chouette jeu on rigole
beaucoup avec la famille et en même
temps on apprend plein de choses parce
que finalement il y a des cartes à
l'intérieur avec de la sensibilisation à
plein de gestes qu'on peut ensuite
appliquer au quotidien tout est à
construire soi-même c'est mis déplier
dans la boîte et c'est tout en carton
voilà la petite tasse c'est moi qui l'ai
rajouté mais sinon il y est pas dans le
jeu et puis vous voyez on a un gros tas
de cartes pleines de défis les cotton
pad donc démaquillant je mets mon
démaquillant dessus et je me démaquille
ou je me nettoie le visage
qui sont réutilisables donc au lieu de
jeter à chaque
nettoyage de la peau je le mets dans mon
linge sale et au bout d'un et puis bah
toutes les semaines je fais mes lessives
quoi et puis ici c'est la petite
pochette pour le savon donc c'est une
pochette que j'ai acheté sur un stand
zéro déchet sur un marché de Noël
ou un marché artisanal elle a un tissu
imperméable à l'intérieur un bouton
pression un joli tissu à l'extérieur et
ça me permet quand je pars en voyage de
mettre mon savon ou mon shampoing solide
dans ma pochette
et voilà
comme ça ça reste propre dans ma trousse
de toilette alors voilà j'espère que ces
petits conseils vous aideront à passer
un Noël plus éco-responsable et sachez
qu'à titre d'exemple un sympa artificiel
est composé de pétrole et de matière
chimiques non renouvelables selon
l'agence de la transition écologique il
faudrait le garder minimum 20 ans pour
limiter son impact environnemental alors
que les Français le gardent en moyenne 3
ans donc on comprend mieux l'intérêt de
ce genre de tuto merci beaucoup Julien
Leroy pour cette sensibilisation que
vous avez fait autour autour de Noël on
continue et on remercie aussi Anna avec
Marc bien sûr qui nous a donné tous ces
bons conseils la décoration le cadeau
même si on a vu tout à l'heure
l'emballage et bien l'emballage aussi
cadeau petite chose aussi sachez que
vous allez retrouver dans les prochains
jours plus de tuto sur les réseaux
sociaux donc voilà si vous voulez
d'autres conseils vous allez voir
on continue dans cette ambiance de Noël
on passe à un événement qui se tenait du
3 au 14 décembre à la Commanderie
d'Élancourt c'était la dernière édition
du Noël décalé au programme marché
d'associations solidaires et de
créateurs locaux activités de création
ou encore dégustation c'était le
week-end dernier
[Musique]
il flottait un air de Noël avant l'heure
à la Commanderie depuis le début du mois
cette année encore le Noël décalé
proposé un programme de fête pour ses
visiteurs le concept c'est de d'offrir
pendant 15 jours un certain nombre de
choses des activités des choses à faire
ou des choses à voir donc cette année et
aujourd'hui c'est le temps fort donc une
journée festive parmi les activités
phares le manège de Monsieur gaillard un
mélange d'attractions et de spectacles
qui a ravi les petits et les grands
[Musique]
manège mais aussi balai aérien ou encore
atelier manuel des associations
solidaires et des créateurs étaient
également présents pour faire découvrir
l'artisanat local je travaille le grès
et donc je façonne des pièces
utilitaires et fonctionnelles en grey je
fais tout à la main de A à Z donc
j'achète la terre sous forme de pain
d'argile et je la prépare je la tourne
je tourne sur un tour de potier et après
je fais la cuisson enfin les maillage là
il y a deux cuissons donc les
différentes cuissons voilà tout le
processus de fabrication en fait et elle
fait complètement artisanalement un
savoir-faire une précision qui se
retrouve dans ce vase jusqu'à sa
décoration en termes de décoration ce
que j'aime beaucoup c'est la
superposition de ces deux émaux il y a
d'abord un noir en dessous on voit la
ligne de démarcation ici et un blanc par
dessus et ça fait toutes ces nuances
bleutées et vertes des stands très
appréciés par les visiteurs c'est des
boutiques à but humanitaires donc plutôt
bien ça permet d'acheter un peu plus
responsable de quoi donner des idées au
Père Noël heureux de faire des cadeaux
éthiques pour les fêtes
un événement passé mais il y aura
d'autres idées à faire pendant les
vacances d'autres idées de sortie
Gabriel Gontier vous avez préparé
justement une petite sélection pour ces
vacances scolaires tout à fait Grégory
et on commence avec l'incontournable
parade de Noël de Poissy alors cette
année encore la magie de Noël s'invite
dans les rues Pisciacaise au programme
une déambulation lumineuse et festive au
travers du centre-ville rendez-vous donc
à 18h samedi pour le départ de la parade
c'est de vendre l'Hôtel de Ville
l'ancien maire de Poissy car le livre
qui avait pour habitude se déguiser en
père Noël et lui-même distribué les
cadeaux
et cette année je pense qu'elle va se
déguiser en Donald Duck
concerne municipal en charge du
bien-être animal c'est ça et de la
biodiversité de la biodiversité dans la
ville de Poissy donc c'est une bonne
idée pour bien commencer ces fêtes de
Noël et toujours dans le thème de
Gabriel que serait nos fêtes sans les
patinoires vous nous avez déjà proposé
quelques endroits où patiner la semaine
dernière ce samedi un nouveau lieu ouvre
ses portes si vous souhaitez glisser oui
la patinoire du centre commercial de
l'espace Saint-Quentin à Montigny ouvre
ce weekend alors en famille ou entre
amis vous pourrez profiter de cet espace
de 96 mètres carrés et pas d'inquiétude
si vous n'êtes pas disponible ce
week-end Mathilde parce que vous avez
jusqu'au 4 janvier pour patiner et la
Bergerie Nationale revêt aussi son
manteau blanc pour pour ces animations
de Noël tout à fait à partir de samedi
et ce pour deux semaines la bergerie
fête Noël de nombreux animations sont
prévues comme des activités de création
vous pourrez également profiter de la
crèche de Noël avec les animaux de la
ferme ou encore de la balade comptée en
calèche je pense que ça va vous plaire
ça non ça c'est pour Rambouillet alors
si on habite du côté de Trappes il y a
également des activités qui sont prévues
tout à fait pour les fêtes de fin
d'année la ville de Trappes organise
plusieurs événements alors il y a quatre
espèces lumineux qui ont été installés
notamment devant l'église ou sur le
parvis de la Merise un marché de Noël
avec des produits artisanaux est aussi
présent vous trouverez aussi des
confiseries des jouets et la patinoire
qui revient cette année 288 m² de
bâtiment et les visiteurs pourront
peut-être croiser le Père Noël Gabriel
oui alors nous on l'a pas eu en plateau
ce soir mais le 23 décembre le Père Noël
prendra un peu de son temps pour rendre
visite aux enfants c'est de 14 heures à
20h30 à la Merise un petit peu de poésie
et de musique le musée départemental
Maurice Ravel à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
propose 6 spectacles gratuits pour les
enfants alors parmi les spectacles du
violon de la danse du cerceau
acrobatique ou encore de la jonglerie et
bien merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces idées de sortie comme
d'habitude est-ce que il y en a une qui
vous tente plus que l'autre autour du
plateau
on va se tenter patinoire
pourquoi pas la patinoire
et je salue d'ailleurs monsieur
Jean-Jacques Nico qui nous prépare cette
belle parade chaque année Julien la
patinoire
on va tester tout ça ensemble bah merci
beaucoup Gabriel pour toutes ces idées
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant on a comme d'habitude
de chaque jeudi le quiz et c'est juste
après
[Musique]
alors pour le quiz on va jouer en nombre
on va demander également aux autres
membres de la rédaction tv78 il y a 5
qui est revenu du centre il est revenu
tout à l'heure en duplex depuis le
centre commercial Westfield Vélizy 2 et
de l'autre côté c'est également de la
rédaction TV 70 bonsoir tu me fais
plaisir d'être présenté voilà est venu
nous voir pour cette émission de Noël
bien sûr qui fait partie de la rédaction
TV 78 Nicolas d'André vous nous avez
préparé
le thème ce soir
qui peuvent vous donner des idées de
cadeaux Mickaël midoro il allait faire
identifier ses cadeaux je sais à
OSP du easy 2 donc peut-être que vous
avez pas avoir besoin néanmoins vous
pouvez jouer et on va jouer aussi avec
des chefs pâtissiers ou des chefs
cuisiniers voilà comme à chaque fois la
soyez attentif aussi aux images et donc
c'est parti première question c'est une
idée de cadeau de Noël et le papa
nouvelle se fournit chez Valérie pour
les cadeaux autour de Coignières
regardez ces images Valérie a fabriqué
ses accessoires de mode vous le voyez
des sacs à main des porte-monnaies des
pochettes des chaises ou encore des sacs
de sport à votre avis à partir de quel
objet Valérie fabrique-t-elle ses
accessoires de mode je le sais mais on
va laisser les autres jouets du
plastique des bouchons
matières objets
exact pour la réponse
vous savez pas on dirait des
imperméables
c'est pas que j'ai triché je me souviens
de ce reportage qu'on avait diffusé à
l'époque c'est des voiles de bateaux
exactement
rouge parce qu'on faisait beaucoup de
rouge à l'époque et du tan et tan c'est
le marron foncé autrement voilà donc je
recycle je récupère même les vieilles
ralingues et tout je dessine d'abord mon
sac et puis après par rapport à la voix
il faut regarder si la voile est encore
bonne donc on la met à laver dans la
machine à laver et puis on voit ce qui
reste et puis après on coupe ces
morceaux en fonction de ce qu'on veut
comme modèle tout simplement après vous
avez tout ce qui est planche à voile
alors c'est des couleurs un peu flashy
parce que les années 70-80 c'était que
des couleurs qu'on voit bien sur l'eau
de très très loin
alors on va faire un voyage dans le
temps pour la deuxième question retour
en 2003 et je vous propose de regarder
ce reportage sur les jouets à la mode
auprès des
en commandes à la main les 50 chinois se
pressent actuellement dans les rayons
joués des grands magasins certains s'ils
sont pris à l'avance d'autres feront
leurs emplettes de Noël à la dernière
minute mais si les méthodes diffèrent
les achats se ressemblent certains
produits sortants nettement du lot pour
ce qui est de tout ce qui est premier
âge on a un produit qui s'appelle Furby
c'est un tigremlins en fait qui évolue
qui parle au début il parle pas trop et
plus vous vous en occupez plus il parle
chez les garçons nous avons une gamme
Action Man qui est la meilleure vente
notamment un produit qui est le Action
Man VTT c'est une gamme très très
complète avec des véhicules des armes
des personnages différents qui vont
aussi bien dans l'eau que dans des
voitures avec des bons des méchants du
côté des filles la poupée Barbie a
toujours la cote surtout la Barbie de
l'an 2000 organisé et documenté les
enfants savent ce qu'ils veulent au pied
du sapin de Noël les seuls jouets
vraiment avec lesquels ils jouent c'est
Action Man c'est l'air d'être la mode
quoi c'est un peu la boule de Barbie du
garçon j'ai l'impression j'ai influencé
par la télé non je sais pas si ça passe
à la télé oui les publicités du matin
c'est de 7h45 à 8h15 le temps du petit
déj attention il ne vous reste plus que
quelques jours pour faire plaisir à vos
enfants d'autant que les produits phares
risquent de disparaître des rayons
alors la question sur ce reportage
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire à quel
prix est le Action Man velo s'il vous
plaît
le Action Man va aller à l'époque 130
neuf euros 90
francs pardon 139 francs 90 juste pour
une petite question autour de ce
reportage est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de ces jouets Action Man Furby oui moi
j'avais un Furby je l'avoue
moi j'avais le petit Power Rangers on
pouvait changer en appuyant sur un
bouton Passer de son visage son vrai
visage à son visage avec le casque de
Power Rangers
mais j'avoue que je me souviens pas trop
on va passer à la troisième question et
on va aller sur le terrain des artisans
alimentaires des Yvelines direction
Guyancourt au sein de l'atelier gâteau
ou le chef pâtissier crée chaque année
avec son équipe des bûches très
surprenante regardez celle de l'année
dernière et donnez-moi au moins trois
ingrédients pour fabriquer cette bûche
que vous voyez à l'image
chocolat du chocolat du sucre et puis
du caramel
un peu
trop facile bon épices alors non mais
alors bon Mathilde avait plusieurs
ingrédients on va tout de suite écouter
la réponse dans cette extrait on va
commencer par mouler un cône en chocolat
et du coup c'est un chocolat qui a un
chocolat Dolce donc c'est un chocolat
qui est un chocolat blanc donc c'est une
base de chocolat blanc qui est
légèrement torréfiée on va utiliser du
coup ce cône pour les garnir avec une
crème au muscovado donc le muscovados
c'est un sucre qui est non raffiné c'est
un sucre qui vient de l'île Maurice qui
est noir affiné on va y ajouter un cœur
coulant de praliné noisette noisette de
France on a eu la chance d'avoir des
noisettes de France cette année donc on
en a profité pour faire un beau praliné
avec ensuite on va ajouter un nouveau
des noisettes
et une dacquoise de la noisette donc on
est vraiment sur le muscovado qui va
être un qui va avoir un goût particulier
la noisette et le praliné
voilà l'atelier gâteau donc pâtisserie
de Guyancourt donc vous aviez le
chocolat le sucre et il y avait aussi la
noisette voilà toujours des bûches assez
surprenantes allez dernière question
regardez ces images c'était l'année
dernière Mathilde est-ce que vous
vous étiez vous étiez bien régalé à ce
moment-là lors de ce tournage n'a pas
n'importe où au Waldor pastoria Trianon
Palace on avait dégusté de très bons
gâteaux j'étais avec vous en tournage
c'est voilà est-ce que vous vous
souvenez du nom du chef et notamment du
nom du menu qui était proposé à ce
moment-là de répondre ou non
alors le nom du chef
pâtissier
[Musique]
je sais plus comment il s'appelle mais
je le connais non
c'était le nom le du menu c'était quoi
qu'est-ce qui était proposé exactement
bravo on va voir la réponse s'afficher
mais Mathilde à dire il a grande
gagnante de de ce quiz bonne mémoire
gustative je pense que ça lui avait
marqué c'est pour ça qu'elle s'en
souvient bien c'était un très beau
reportage et c'était très bon ce qui
nous avait préparé
de Versailles merci beaucoup Nicolas
dandry on retrouve bien sûr vos quiz
tout au long de la saison le jeudi sur
TV 78 on a eu l'occasion de jouer avec
de nombreux sujets c'est bientôt déjà la
fin de cette édition à faire peut-être
un petit tour de table pour voir ce que
vous avez prévu si vous souhaitez en
parler vous avez le droit de garder le
secret mais qu'est-ce que vous avez
prévu pour les fêtes de fin d'année ATIS
je serais en Normandie chez mes
beaux-parents en famille avec mon mari
et mes enfants et mes beaux-parents
chocolat danderie et Céline Charle on va
refaire un petit tour également en régie
puisque et cette édition est aussi
rendue possible avec tous les personnes
présentes en régime vous voyez
n'attendez des idées qui étaient notre
réalisateur sur cette émission Ludovic
Lenny à gauche Xavier j'avais sur la
droite et Mélanie pocket la chef
d'orchestre de cette émission à notre
chef d'édition et on va voir également
Thomas Fletcher qui était à la caméra
volante voilà qui elle nous a permis
également de pouvoir
Tyson aujourd'hui il a fait son petit
pull de Noël personnalisé TV 78
peut-être que Thomas vous donnera tous
ces bons conseils pour le réaliser chez
vous merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
merci Mathilde merci Grégory c'est un
plaisir d'être avec vous c'est un
plaisir partagé on vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous et des bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
aussi également
[Musique]